so tell us a little bit about your life
connor i'm curious what kind of life
have you had you seem like a happy
well-adjusted fellow you also seem
really cool yeah you do you seem really
cool i try to be yeah i i'm
i don't think i am i uh uh i'm a tall
lanky guy like you conan i uh so i've
i've had the same uh
life growing up ridiculed for just being
a lanky tall giant excuse me i was never
ridiculed for that i don't know sorry
praised
connor i don't connor you just went way
out on a limb
well conan like you uh i've
been mocked and ridiculed my entire life
i have the same shape face as you conan
and uh
to this day i'm a virgin yeah supposed
to me too yeah exactly
just guessing the weirdest [ __ ] yeah um
like you conan my urine stream is
weak
and bubbly oh
well
possibly
it depends you probably have to live in
a special home that's been designed for
you did you did you have an architect
come in and change the doorways for you
because i top out at 6'4 which means i
can still live in a regular house
although when i was in your house
gourley there were times where i felt uh
like when i'd go use the powder room i
think i could
i could tear my way into the other part
of the house with just my bare hands
that little bathroom is the tiniest
bathroom yeah and i put my hands on
either side of my body and i thought i
could just push and the whole house
would collapse yeah we literally have to
put a corner sink and a corner toilet in
there because there's not room for
standard versions of that right right
now i did note that and thought i gotta
bring an airplane podcast you're welcome
in the normal bathroom if you'd like no
no i liked it in there
i felt it it was like one of those
weighted blankets
i felt very comfortable
lying in there i just laid down on the
floor and curled up in the fetal
position in your bathroom and you went
in there thinking about just destroying
his house oh i did i thought
i was there and it's very beautiful and
very nice but there's you know when
you're a larger guy and you're in a
smaller house you do fantasize about
tearing it apart
do you do that connor
yeah
oh yeah i uh i i recently moved into a
house and i i tore out walls and i got
to customize it to make it a little bit
bigger
and just sort of things like doorways a
little higher you have like a kaiju
complex yeah yeah i don't know what that
means yeah like a godzilla oh well
godzilla just say godzilla kaiju
encompasses all great monsters mothra
ghidra well no i don't have a guitar or
a mothra complex i do have a godzilla
complex so you shouldn't say
you know you should you should specify
how am i to know what kind of kaiju
complex you have i'd rather look at me
do i look like a mothra do i look like a
mothra to you you really want me to
answer that yes i do oh my god okay uh
listen i'm sorry connor
it's so embarrassing when we welcome you
into our
very small podcast home
and you at six seven come in and we
start fighting uh and uh you are forced
to go into our podcast powder room and
tear it apart i feel terrible for you
and for everyone involved
um but you uh you seem like a happy
well-adjusted fellow you're six seven i
think that's a great height yeah any
taller and too tall it's too tall you
think six seven is too tall yeah i can't
uh i can't get jeans or uh
t-shirts a little easier you can get
them on the internet but um i i tried
looking up that place that goldblum was
talking about where he suggested you go
and get your jeans in la yeah schaefer
garment hotel like the something hotel
shaffer garment hotel hollywood prices
though uh well they weren't i mean first
of all they seemed reasonable to me and
uh well
you're different you have a different
scale yeah i don't think so i think 35
000 for a pair of jeans is very
reasonable and i put them in i put them
in the back of my testerosa drove to my
helicopter and came right home and and
so my life is just like yours connor all
of conan's jeans are insured yeah yeah
yeah lloyd's of london ensures each ass
cheek of my jeans
well connor i'm kind of fascinated with
you you're six seven and you look that
effortlessly cool seeing you walk down
the street must just make people's day
um
yeah i guess so people like to stare
it's a little i get used to it i don't
mean just because you're tall but you
just you you present a really uh
pleasing package oh my god i'm not just
saying what do you get
just follow me once you get a room with
a corner toilet and a corner sink what's
up look at this guy he's a lovable
scoundrel he's got a cleft chin fine
head occur russell hair you do look like
a disney prince a little bit yeah i do
okay i don't i've been looking at the
bookcase behind him so i guess
something's wrong with me
why
i'm just saying i always go to the books
you know like cool
those look interesting oh he's got
vonnegut he's got slaughterhouse five
he's got breakfast of champions i wonder
if he has that in another room